I wasn't planning on carrying you over,
but you're making it very tempting.
Hold on.
They've got turbos up top.
We're running out of road.
Exactly. A stealth exit.
Boys, let's move.
I thought at the end of the war
it would mean an end to losing more of our brothers.
But I was wrong.
We can't just walk away.
Not with the Empire.
Imprisoning a kid.
Secure her in a cell.
Omega has been waiting for us a long time.
Our mission
is not over yet.
There is nothing of greater importance
to secure the future of this empire.
Whatever is needed to accomplish this goal,
you will have it.
They are coming
for all of you.
Give us a real challenge.
Everyone down.
We're not big on following orders.
Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie
There's a brand new bad batch Season 3 trailer
the Star Wars just released.
There's a bunch of Easter eggs here.
Asajj Ventress is back.
Everybody wondering we never see her again.
So obviously, we'll break it down
if you're brand new to the channel.
Be sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
starting with probably the biggest question now.
Everybody wondering, does this mean that Dave
Filoni is going to do Asajj ventress
later in live action during the Mandalorian
and part of the timeline.
Like we have the Thrawn movie.
There's the Grogu movie, Ahsoka Season two,
The Mandalorian.
Season four is a lot of stuff happening
in that part of the timeline where Asajj Ventress
could show up as an older version of the character.
for those of
you that didn't keep up with
what happened to her outside of the clone
Wars series because the last time
we actually saw her in any of the series,
any of the episodes anywhere was in Clone Wars
Season five episode two, which was years ago.
At this point.
that was meant to be the episode where Ahsoka leaves
the Jedi order.
She was actually there to help them
find out about Berra's office.
So she actually wound up helping Ahsoka in.
And again, in the cool thing about Asajj Ventress,
I mean, there are a lot of cool things,
but one of the cool things about her and Asoka
is that they have a fairly parallel storyline.
They both felt abandoned by their masters.
Her by Count Dooku more literally abandoned and then
turned up like Count Dooku literally tried to kill her.
And again, to his credit, did try to help Asoka
try to get her to stay all those years ago.
And he's helping her in present day
in his current force ghost form.
So we don't want to throw Anakin under the bus.
Even though Asajj Ventress
definitely abandoned by her master.
but part of the idea is that the Knights sisters
actually win against Count Dooku.
He tried to eradicate all of them unsuccessfully.
He killed most of them, though, on Dathomir,
she and Mother Townsend survived that attack.
Asajj Ventress goes on her own to survive,
just keeping under the radar, keeping off count.
Dooku Has radar just in general
became more of a bounty hunter to survive,
then came back during that Clone Wars
Season five Episode 22 Help Ahsoka
with Bear is off then, after that episode,
we don't really see her again.
Eventually
what happens is that she meets up with Quinlan Vos.
The two of them start working together.
She fell in love with them, constructed a yellow light
saber to replace her lost Sith lightsabers.
Then the two of them go on a mission to kill Count
Dooku again before the events of Revenge of the Sith.
She winds up sacrificing herself to save Quinlan Vos,
taking the brunt of Count
Dooku is Force Lightning Blast seemingly dying,
but she survives.
Quinlan Vos basically takes her body
in, dumps her in a pool of magic.
That green energy
that the Knights sisters use is basically force energy
And that was meant to be the last you hear of her.
Like you're kind of wondering what happened to her
the bad, bad showrunners, Dave Filoni, all those people
claim that nothing that they're doing with her
during season three tramples on any of Dark Disciple.
It's all still Canon.
The bad batch is meant to take place
well after the events of that book.
So the whole idea is that she survived order 66.
She was alive.
She does continue being a bounty hunter
in the outer rim, staying off the Empire's
radar presumably because she didn't
want to be hunted down by Darth Vader
in the inquisitors because she was for sensitive,
even though technically she left the Sith Order.
She wasn't Sith anymore. She wasn't Jedi either.
She did make this yellow light saber end,
even though it seemed like Darth Vader
and the inquisitors were mostly concerned
with hunting down anybody who was former Jedi in
Survival Order 66, in reality, they were hunting down
anybody who was forged sensitive at all.
No matter what their alignment was.
basically, if they caught you
and you were for sensitive, if you weren't Jedi or you
weren't said like you were untrained,
they would throw you into
training to become another inquisitor
or they would kill you on the spot
because more often than not,
Darth Vader didn't want a ton of force sensitive people
that the Emperor controlled
Because he didn't want the emperor
to betray him by training another successor
and then getting rid of him.
so basically, Darth Vader was trying to get rid
of all the competition, all of these different years.
He didn't care if they found
and saved more for sensitive people,
even if most of them wound up becoming inquisitors.
the whole truth of the matter is that he didn't care
about any of the inquisitors either.
Like he would kill them
just as quickly as he kill other former Jedi.
one of the great jokes of Star Wars in the fandom
is that Darth Vader killed almost as many Imperials is
the rebels Did
But either way, this means Asajj Ventress
definitely survived
the events of Revenge of the Sith Order 66.
She's alive and well in present day,
which is why I say that she can.
She's able to come back in present day
during the events of the Mandalorian series.
Ahsoka Season two, for instance.
There are couple other Easter eggs
here in the trailer too.
Like it looks like they go back to the 10th planet.
that was also the location of a fight
that she had with Obi-Wan Kenobi during the Clone Wars.
So there are some locations that they visit
that are specific to her character in their history.
In the Clone
Wars, it's not exactly clear what she's doing.
During the events of bad batch season three, but
she'll probably wind up helping the clones get Omega
back in a fight against the Emperor, even though
she isn't like a good person, quote unquote.
Like she isn't good alignment.
She's more neutral right now.
she's basically a bounty hunter out to earn more money.
it is probably just one of those situations
where she winds up helping the bad batch clones.
they're probably a couple of jokes that they have
when they meet her for the first time, too.
Like, they probably try to kill her
because the last they remember of her,
she was actually serving Count Dooku.
She was evil. She was said.
but if you think about it this way, Dave Filoni
just brought the nice sisters back.
They just went to Dathomir
at the end of Asoka Season one.
Does it not make sense to bring Asajj Ventress back
during Ahsoka season two and have her help?
Ahsoka with the Nine Sisters?
Like, let me tell you about all these problems
that they're going to be causing around the galaxy now
Speaking of her connection to Mother Tauzin,
they just brought back
the sword of the sword that Mother Talisman wielded
during Ahsoka season one.
So everything
the nicest was just did in general coming back
during this part of the timeline
not exactly clear who would play her in live action.
It could be pretty much anybody.
and because the nice sisters dathomir and race ages
a little bit more slowly
and because of the way they use their magic.
You could also cast a slightly younger actress
who's about on par with Ahsoka's age and present day to
even though technically she's meant to be much older
than Asoka is one of those Star Wars
issues where you have different races,
aging at different rates.
They also bring back CAD Bane,
who we last saw during the book of Boba Fett.
Remember,
this is after the events of Revenge of the Sith
when this is taking place,
but before the events of the Obi-Wan Kenobi series.
I don't know if we're going to see Quinlan Boss
either, because he's also alive.
During the events of the Obi-Wan Kenobi series.
Not exactly
Clear to if the Ventures is still in contact with him
in present day.
A lot of people wondering
if we were going to see him in a live action, too.
At some point.
I think we will.
Like, why else would you say that
he's still alive during Obi-Wan Kenobi? but.
Jumping back to the beginning of the trailer,
they confirmed that Feige, you know,
played by Wanda Sykes
character, is back from season two.
She helped the clones out earlier.
She's just helping them out on this mission here.
no, the big person coming back.
Captain Rex, who is also featured in live action
during Asoka season one,
even though it was kind of a flashback
that Asoka was seeing during the events
of the Clone Wars, like their live action Clone Wars
flashbacks.
we'll probably see more from him in live action
eventually too,
because he's still alive in present day
during the events of The Mandalorian.
All that stuff,
just a much older version of the character.
Also played by Tamura Morrison,
one of the benefits of playing characters
like Boba Fett
is that all the clones basically look like you.
They made a joke about that
during the Mandalorian Season two, where they're like,
How come you can't take your helmet off?
Will they probably recognize me
because he looks like all the clones.
They make a couple references to Tex death
during season two.
Everybody's still heartbroken about that.
And there is a brand new bounty hunter
who seems kind of mysterious,
but his armor looks a little bit like tex armor.
Then they make a bunch of references to everything
that's happening
at Mount Tantas in Omega being their prisoner,
trying to rescue her.
Essentially, the whole idea?
They I've been watching the bad batch episodes
is that Mount Tantas is a cool bit of legends.
Canada Dave Filoni brought back into the main canon
and it's from
the original Thrawn
trilogy of books like Heir to the Empire.
he's been slowly re canonizing all that stuff,
like Thrawn is now back in live action.
but part of the idea is that originally
in the Thrawn books, that's where the Emperor kept
Luke's severed hand and it was used during a big
cloning plotline during that original Thrawn trilogy
where they tried to clone the Jedi Master
and then they tried to clone Luke.
what Dave Filoni has done now
in present day with this version of Mount Tantas
is explained that the emperor is using it
for his cloning experiments,
trying to create a force sensitive clone
so that he can continue his life,
basically start hopping bodies,
which you saw during the live action sequel movies.
Somehow, Palpatine returned that's
why during the trailer
where you see him inside Mount Kansas,
he says, this is the most important thing we're doing.
You will have any resources you need to complete this
task during the events of the Mandalorian.
They reference it as Project Necromancer,
and it's the people who are part of the first order,
that faction of the Shadow Council that are actually
continuing that later in the timeline.
But this is obviously happening
like right after Revenge of the Sith.
Dr. Hemlock is the lead Imperial Scientist
at Mount Tantalus here.
He's one of the main antagonist of the season.
He was the person that was trying to force Nulla, say,
one of the Camino
ins, who was in charge of their cloning technology
in their process
to help them figure out a way
to clone the emperor's body.
she thinks of Omega as her daughter
because she basically created
Omega now the Empire is using Omega against her.
Like,
if you don't help us, then we're going to kill Omega.
They also just revealed at the end of season two
that Emery Carr, one of the other doctors
who's working at the cloning facility on Mount
Tantas, is another female clone,
basically Omega sister, whereas previously Omega
thought she was the only female clone.
It is The Emery Car is an older version of Omega.
no. I know a lot of people.
Other big question
they've had after all the bad batch episodes
the last couple of seasons is will
they do Omega in live action eventually too,
because they've already brought back
a bunch of live action versions of the clones
in that part of The Mandalorian timeline,
like Boba Fett came back.
Obviously, Commander Rex came back
even though it was technically a flashback.
So now we have Asajj Ventress
probably coming back in live action and probably
a version of Omega eventually, but we haven't heard
too much about Omega coming back in live action.
Speaking of people coming back,
there's a bit of a reverse version of that happening
with Ming-Na, Wen's character Fennec Shand.
She's going to show up again, but she also starred
during previous seasons of the Bad Batch,
just a younger version of her character
before she got all of her Darth Vader cybernetic parts.
Later in the timeline,
Thank you very much, Boba Fett for having her fixed up.
there's a whole bunch other stuff happening
during this bad batch trailer, too.
Like, there's a bunch of crosshairs footage here.
He's being held captive at Mount Tantas.
They implied that he's also rebelling
against the Empire, so he might turn back
to help the clones again during season three,
whereas he turned on them previously.
he's had his whole big arc these last couple
of seasons, like The Fall of Crosshairs.
Now, I think they're trying to do the redemption
of crosshairs.
in it does seem like there's going to be a lot more
Emperor Palpatine during this part of the season.
posted the entire schedule of episodes.
They'll be 15 total,
but it'll be a three episode premiere.
So this is when all the episodes will be releasing
They're a couple other
big Star Wars series that are dropping this year.
So the other animated one
is going to be Tales of the Jedi.
That'll be later this year.
Don't know exactly when that's going to be releasing.
But we also have the Star Wars Skeleton Crew series.
That's another spin off of The Mandalorian
in the Sokka.
Those characters will appear in
either the Grogu movie or the Thrawn movie.
then we have the Star Wars acolyte series.
But that's like a totally different thing.
Not really connected to what's happening
on The Mandalorian.
It's taking place during the High Republic era long
before the events of the prequels,
more likely that we'll see a younger version of Yoda,
slightly younger.
He still would have been pretty old during then,
but much younger, looking a little more spry.
maybe, Maybe a young version of Palpatine.
we'll probably get trailers for that stuff
at some point in the next couple of months.
there was a bunch of Star Wars news
about what's happening with all the upcoming movies
and the upcoming series
during The Mandalorian part of the timeline, Click
Here for that Ahsoka Season 2 teaser
and click here for that
brand new Invincible Season 2 Episode 5 Trailer.
Thank you so much for watching
and I'll see you guys in the next one!